next presentation which is going to be
they already have started so smile turn
off your phones and beepers you'll have
to watch it when it's we run this
evening no time to call home and say
look at me okay
before you leave today for the LAT the
last presentation please remember to
recycle your badges will have a box here
or outside it's green it's big and we're
going to do the good thing for oh I
heard something okay is that what they
sound like some of them during the first
presentation when Ralph Nader was here
my phone was sitting right here and I
had not cycled it off and I prayed for
an hour that no one would call me no one
did I want you to look at the back of
your programs and notice our sponsors
and throughout the year please patronize
them watch them on TV listen to them on
the radio
buy their products and thank them for
being sponsors of Miami Book Fair
International we couldn't do it without
them yes
to introduce our next panel it is my
pleasure to welcome back Charles Chapman
a friend of Miami Book Fair
International and a frequent and
wonderful introducer
Charles thank you Barbara
today we have three prominent
journalists they will each speak for a
relatively short time and then there
will be plenty of questions because I'm
sure many of you want to know what they
think about just about everything first
up we have Chris Hedges uncompromising
is how most journalists except maybe
those for English tabloids regard
themselves in the case of Chris Hedges
it's the real thing he covered the war
it's in the Balkans for the New York
Times during the 1990s and then went on
to be the Middle East bureau chief for
that paper currently he writes an online
column for TruthDig and was recently
awarded the Los Angeles Press prize for
best online column for the year the
titles of his books speak for themselves
I don't believe in atheism in atheists
American fascists the Christian Right
and the war on America the ironically
titled war is a force that gives us
meaning his current publication is
Empire of illusion the end of literacy
and the triumph of spectacle next up
we'll have George Packer George made his
mark on international reporting in 2005
with the publication of the assassins
gate it tells that the invasion and
occupation of Iraq appearing on nearly
every list of best books
that year at won numerous journalistic
awards as well after graduating from
Yale in 1982 and working for the Peace
Corps he became a staff writer for The
New Yorker and in 2000 wrote blood of
the Liberals his current book is called
interesting times writings from a
turbulent decade our third author is sam
Tanenhaus currently the editor of the
New York Times Book Review and The
Sunday weekend review section since
receiving his degree in English from
Grinnell and picking up a master's from
Yale he has written and edited for
Vanity Fair and The Times his 1997
biography of Whittaker Chambers was a
finalist for the National Book Award and
for the Pulitzer Prize in biography this
year he has produced the death of
conservatism which has become a focal
point in current political debate
especially in the wake of the recent
elections please welcome our three
authors
hi we're each going to talk for five
minutes I guess the Reader's Digest
version of our books my book Empire of
illusion the end of literacy and the
triumph of spectacle makes the argument
that we are the most illusioned nation
on the planet that we have become
utterly disconnected from who we are
what we represent and where we're going
and replaced it with fantasy it has
allowed us to run offshore penal
colonies where we openly torture other
human beings suspend habeas corpus
engage in warrantless wiretapping and
eavesdropping of American civilians
lived through a banana republic 2000
election where unfortunately this state
contributed to the theft of the
Democratic vote and yet described
ourselves as the greatest democracy on
earth a democracy that abrogates the
right to impose its virtues on others by
force we have built a system of
unfettered capitalism which has turned
everything from human beings to the
natural environment into commodities for
exploitation until exhaustion or
collapse this has hollowed out America
from the inside it's why we are
borrowing roughly at a rate of two
billion dollars a day from the Chinese
and have been for the last ten years at
some point that has to collapse we have
destroyed our manufacturing base and
described it as an opportunity for
growth all of these things have fed into
I think a very frightening fantasy about
where we're headed that we have in many
ways remained 40 year-old children
unable to confront the the as the
historian Harvard historian Charles
Mayor calls it that transition from an
empire of production to an empire of
consumption
real wages in this country have remained
stagnant since 1973 and just as we
maintain Empire through credit and
borrowing we maintain a lifestyle that
we can no longer afford through credit
and borrowing all of that is collapsing
one strives towards a dream one lives
within an illusion and the illusion that
we are fed is the reality is never an
impediment to what we want that we can
if we just dig deep enough within
ourselves if we find our inner strength
if we grasp as Tony Robbins says that we
are truly exceptional if we believe that
Jesus can perform miracles if we focus
on happiness we can fulfill this
pernicious psychological idea among
consumer culture that has a sort of
instilled massive consumption as a kind
of inner compulsion and the danger of
illusion is that it allows you to remain
in a state of perpetual childishness
infantile ISM and as that gap opens up
between the illusion of who we are and
the reality the foreclosures the
bankruptcies that are caused by the
inability to pay medical bills the
collapse of empire we are unprepared
emotionally psychologically and
intellectually for what it is that is
about to confront us and when the wolf
finally pays at the door when our house
is foreclosed when the unemployment
insurance runs out then you react if you
have remained in a state of illusion as
a child reacts you search for a
demagogue or a savior who promises moral
renewal vengeance and new glory and we
can already see that very frightening
psychological disease leaping up around
the fringes of American society the only
way that one can speak about hope is to
break free from a non reality based
belief system to begin to speak in a new
language of humility to
cept a lifestyle which frees itself from
profligate consumption and endorses a
new simplicity and it finally it is not
incidental or accidental that the
environmental crisis we face is twinned
with the economic crisis it stems from
the same disease which is turning
everything human beings into a commodity
the natural environment into a commodity
that we exploit and end and and exhaust
until it dies and either we wake from
this illusion or we commit collective
suicide
just 15 minutes ago Chris was saying he
had no idea what he was going to say and
I thought I had some idea now I have to
try to duplicate that I will not
duplicate that my book is a collection
of pieces of essays that were published
during a period that I think of now is
kind of already a little bit in the past
and a distinct period September 11th
2001 to November 4th 2008
when Tara was visited on us I think we
had and squandered certain possibilities
in the way we responded to it and at the
end of that period of waste and
squandering we showed that in spite of
Chris's I think in some ways accurate
and also quite savage analysis we show
we're capable of some self-criticism and
some self renewal on November 4th 2008
the the pieces in the in interesting
times are largely foreign reporting and
there are a particular kind of foreign
story their long-form narrative
journalism which is probably soon to be
one of those things that among the list
of soon-to-be-extinct aspects of our
culture unless journalism takes a sharp
turn for the better
I was writing mostly for The New Yorker
during those years to Lamb and although
some of the pieces are about our Wars
our wars in Iraq Afghanistan
counterinsurgency a lot of them are
about parts of the world that were sort
of forgotten during that time West
Africa East Africa Burma and I'll just
tell you a quick story of something I
saw in the West African country of ivory
coast to give you a sense of what the
larger themes of the book are Ivory
Coast was undergoing a terrible civil
war in the early part of the decade and
I visited at one of the bad depths of
that civil war and I started seeing in
the up
sort of northwest part of the country
these young 14 15 even 13 12 year old
fighters with ak-47s and t-shirts that
said they were like action t-shirts one
face was Osama bin Laden the other face
was George W Bush and I had never seen
such a t-shirt before what did it mean I
mean it had the two faces of the
protagonists of the war on terror on it
and from talking to these guys these
young guys I began I think it really
just means power that these are the two
sort of cartoon Titans dominating the
world of war right now and these young
guys want to be part of power and where
do they get these ideas well they
probably got them from the global media
which they had access to even in the
some pretty remote parts of Ivory Coast
they were able to watch BBC they were
able to watch CNN they were able to
watch al-jazeera and they had in their
head kind of a crazy mishmash of images
and slogans and ideas some of it came
from hip-hop and gangsta rap culture in
this country some of it came from
jihadism even though these guys you know
were were half drunk the whole time I
was with them one of them said to me
that he wanted to go join the jihad and
Osama was the only guy who would give
him a good job another guy said he
wanted to join the US Marines but they
were all you know kind of fighting
together in the same rather anarchic
insurgency and Ivory Coast and I spoke
with an Italian doctor who was doing
humanitarian work in Ivory Coast and and
told him about these things I was seeing
and he said yes he said this is a
perverse effect of globalization he
called it contagion by media in other
words it used to be that guys like this
from small villages whose sense of the
world pretty much stopped at the edges
of the village and I got to know guys
like that when I was in the Peace Corps
in the early 80s that world is over
these guys now have a notion of the
world
but it's a very skewed and slanted and
jagged and fragmented notion that comes
from mainly from images and these images
mainly come through satellite TV and the
web and far from knitting the world
together global media seems to at least
in this stage to be driving the world
apart to be making it a more violent
place to be giving us not a better idea
of each other but a more violent and
simplistic and cartoon like ID of each
other it's stoking hatreds and in the
case of these young guys envy because
that was their main feeling was Envy
there's all this stuff out there in the
world and they can't have it they can't
reach it they can almost read you a
French scholar and I Rico said to me
it's it's less vitrine she said in
French meaning window licking it's not
window shopping because that means you
can go in and buy it's window licking
these guys were looking in the window at
the world through global media and
wanted it and they're frustrated
aspirations we're sort of literally
driving them crazy
certainly driving them to pick up a gun
and so in that part of the world global
media seem to be producing frustration
and alienation in the Muslim and Arab
world where I spent quite a bit of time
especially in Iraq it was bombarding
young people with selective images of
violence that was creating a very
intense but very narrow view of the
world and the West and filling their
heads through the internet with a lot of
conspiracy theories that may had a basis
in reality but took them very far from
reality and on our part we were getting
a very sanitized view of the wards that
we had started and were you know through
this sort of the appearance of
information on places like seeing and
we're actually not getting much in the
way of useful information at all we were
bombarded I mean we've never been more
saturated with information but it has
not led to more clarity it hasn't led to
more complexity in our thinking and I
think it by the
end of this period 2001 to eight it led
to a desire to just shut it off we had
been overloaded with information about
the world especially about countries
where we were at war fatigue set in and
we wanted it to stop so where does
interesting times come in the kind of
journalism that I and some colleagues do
is an attempt at least to get past that
level of communication in which you're
essentially being bombarded with images
like electrons and instead to use words
and lots of words I mean The New Yorker
is you know one of the very last places
on earth where you can publish 15,000
words on a subject and where you can not
only do that but you can write about
ordinary people out almost every one of
my stories in the book is essentially
about people who are not famous not
powerful ordinary people and it tells
the stories of their lives why is that
worth hearing because it first of all
it's a way to get readers to read and
it's hard to get readers to read a lot
of words about foreign countries we're
an insular nation but I think during
this period there was a curiosity for a
while about the rest of the world which
was one of the sort of odd good things
that came out of 9/11 and not just to
get them to read but to get them to
understand how ordinary people think
about their own lives that became sort
of the goal of my reporting was to get
at how people who in some ways are right
on the receiving end of our policies and
who in the world we live in in the end
are going to have an effect on us as
well how do they see themselves how do
they see the world I mean it's a limited
form because as a journalist I'm an
expert in nothing I don't speak Arabic I
don't speak Burmese I get to go in for
say three weeks at a time so this cannot
replace expertise it's a it's an amateur
not in a totally bad way it's an
amateurish form and but it's the best
way I know of to try to explain to
readers here what's going on in the
heads and lives of people
who
we see in these flickering images on in
global media and the question is does
this form have any future and I'm not
sure it does and if it if it doesn't
then I think we'll all be a little bit
the worse for it
I know we want to get to questions at
some point is that right so I'll be very
brief just as these guys have been but
I've less to say so I'll be even briefer
and then maybe we can get to questions
right away my book is called the death
of conservatism it's a short historical
narrative about the rise the triumphs
then the decline and death I think of
this very important modern political and
intellectual movement it starts with a
new deal and takes us through Obama's
administration it goes at a very fast
clip it's about not ordinary people
though it may be about my non-reality
based belief system it's really about
extraordinary people some of whom have
been almost forgotten thinkers like
James Burnham and Wilmore Kendall the
late William F Buckley who probably a
lot of people in this audience do know
and how they shaped an idea of
conservatism that came to dominate our
politics for several decades and then
gradually lost its its direction and
focus as it was taken over by what we
think of as movement conservatism so the
book really describes two strains of
modern conservatism one is what I call a
classical conservatism of Edmund Burke
Benjamin Disraeli this was the idea that
conservatism is a philosophy that should
hold a culture and society together
largely through the instruments of
government believe it or not and some of
the figures who personified that
conservatism in our own politics
included Dwight Eisenhower in his best
days Richard Nixon who was one of the
most liberal presidents of the modern
era in many ways and I think Bill
Clinton who was the last great
conservative president we had and I
briefly explained why I think Clinton
was a conservative president explained
in the book is he was a mirror image of
Dwight Eisenhower these were two
presidents who followed a series of of
presidencies dominated by the opposition
party which had worked large
transformations in the society
Eisenhower came into office in 1953 was
elected in 52
after five consecutive democratic
presidencies something that's
inconceivable today the Republicans did
not win a presidential election in the
1930s or 40s and Eisenhower who came
into office as the first Republican was
expected by some to roll back or unravel
the New Deal policies of Franklin
Roosevelt and Harry Truman and he didn't
do it and the reason he didn't do it was
he saw the policies worked and that the
country expected the government to have
some role in society then if you flash
forward to nineteen ninety-three forty
years later when Bill Clinton took
office he followed three Republican
presidents this short but tumultuous age
of Reagan is it sometimes called though
I think it actually began earlier with
Richard Nixon and Clinton came into
office as a kind of Barack Obama as a
kind of Kennedy and Johnson a democratic
liberal Liberal Democrat and saw that
the country for better or worse seemed
in aggregate to have accepted and this
may have been a big mistake on Clinton's
part the free market policies of the
previous president so what he decided to
do was to moderate them but not to undo
them and so in that sense both
Eisenhower and Clinton strike me as
classically conservative figures on the
other side are the movement
conservatives the most visible right now
is Sarah Palin whose new book is out and
we saw eight years of movement
conservatism under George Bush the
consequences of which both Chris and
George have described to some extent
this is a conservatism that's based on a
kind of organized hatred of liberal
enemies and also of government and
society and social institutions
universities the the media the legal
profession people who work for local
state and federal governments are all
seen essentially as dangerous or enemy
figures by movement
and so what they gave us was the
conservatism that by any classical
definition really sounds like radicalism
and I think the nearest parallel to some
of the so-called conservative protests
we saw over the summer was the
anti-government protests that came on
the left in the in the late 1960s it's a
it's a politics of a Daniel Bell called
antinomianism the distrust of all
institutional values and so I think
we're fortunate to some extent to have a
president now who by this classical
definition has very strongly
conservative instincts Barack Obama so
that's the story my book tries to tell
and so maybe now where is our moderator
there you are maybe we can get to some
questions or debates or arguments or
whatever yes there's a microphone
because you really nail it right on the
head with Empire of illusion it's
exactly what is happening to this world
today in the grips of these monstrous
money B's madmen that run this money
system and capitalism and the
militarization coming out of the
Pentagon but I would like to ask you you
speak of the spectacle triumph of
spectacle
how have they gotten away with the
September 11th supreme hoaxes big lie
what do you think of the evidence of the
crime of 9/11 and who was responsible
for placing the explosives in those New
York's but let me deal with spectacle
first and then I'll deal with 9/11 it
was interesting hearing Sam's analysis
some of which I agree with I'm actually
a fan of Eisenhower and in political
terms to find myself as a conservative
in a sense that embracing karl popper's
kind of piecemeal engineering the the
deep distrust of utopianism but I think
Sam has confused something and that is
that we have shifted from conservatism
which in many ways was a positive force
and is a positive force in democratic
societies to corporatism and that's
something very different that the kind
of penny capitalism that took place I
grew up in a farm town where farmers
came in and so their goods even a
regional capitalism where the guy of the
load in our local hardware store sat on
the school board that has been destroyed
for corporate capitalism which has
radically upended our politics and when
you talk about Clinton Clinton made a
very conscious decision to take
corporate money and do the bidding of
corporate donors he understood that if
he did that he could have fundraising
parity with the Republicans which he did
by the 1990s and of course now the
Democrats get more and but to do the
bidding of corporatism men he
accelerated what began in the Reagan
administration which wasn't conservatism
but a kind of coup d'etat and slow
motion in which the citizens were
utterly disempowered to sir
corporate interests and that became
justified through the utopian ideology
of globalism of free-market capitalism
something Karl Polanyi in his great 1944
work the great transformation understood
that when a society loses the capacity
for the sacred when you build a system
where human beings are discarded like
human refuse as we are seeing with our
blue collar and I come out of the blue
collar so it's something that has
affected my own family you build a kind
of neo feudalism and that's where we're
headed so I think we have to make the
distinction between conservatism and
corporatism and we live in a corporate
state as Sheldon Wolin in democracy
incorporated probably our greatest
living political philosopher has
explained inverted totalitarianism
unlike classical totalitarianism finds
his expression in the anonymity of the
corporate state not in a demagogue not
in a charlatan in a charismatic leader
it a it doesn't tear down a structure it
purports to cherish democracy electoral
politics while subverting the levers of
power it in in classical totalitarianism
uu politics always Trump's economics and
inverted totalitarianism economics
Trump's politics with different kinds of
ruthlessness and I think that
transformation while we still use the
language of traditional conservatism and
the iconography of American patriotism
has masked something deeply insidious
which is why we are where we are now
just on 9/11 I my friend Amy Goodman
unfortunately we get these questions all
the time I am a denier in that sense I
don't think it was a conspiracy
I covered al Qaeda for the New York
Times out of Paris including huge
investigations into Mohamed Atta and I
think the reason 9/11 worked is because
Atta was brilliant and disciplined
obviously deeply psychotic and without
it without him it wouldn't have worked
just to be fair to you I also have not
studied the structural analysis and
which some people have who make that
claim that you know this was
orchestrated but as someone who did
spend a year of my life covering
al-qaeda it's my impression that it's
more that the Bush administration was
asleep of the switch unless that there
was active involvement I don't believe
there was active involvement in the
attacks of 9/11 for next for mr. hedges
Obama was against invading Iraq in 2002
he promised change in 2008 once he was
president he appointed George Bush's
Secretary of Defense to be Secretary of
Defense and now the American military
presence in Iraq and Afghanistan is far
greater than it was under George Bush
please explain because Obama is a brand
Obama you know he think of Obama the way
remember when Calvin Klein and Benetton
associated risque style and HIV models
and all this stuff to give their
products an edge and a progressive
appeal but of course the end result was
the same which is to make consumers
confused a brand with an experience that
is what Obama provided he has as you
correctly point out not veered from the
policies endorsed either financial or
military by the Bush administration the
kinds of arguments that occur between
the Democrats and the Republicans are as
Freud says essentially about the
narcissism of minor difference we see
the rise of the corporatism corporate
state in every aspect including the
health care debate any factual
discussion of health care in this
country would begin with the
acknowledgment that the for-profit
health care industry is the problem and
must be destroyed there
this is an industry this is an industry
that has the legal right to hold sick
children hostage while their parents
bankrupt themselves to save their sons
and daughters and the inability to have
a rational discussion around health care
is driven because Obama sadly is largely
a figurehead and has been emasculated by
the corporate forces that have
orchestrated the largest transference of
wealth upwards in American history and
are destroying a country that I love
another question for you Chris
if Haley's you guys are feeling I know I
feel but I got to ask this if you had
been president in 2007 in your Treasury
secretary came to you and said you got
to come up with a quarter of a billion
to save the financial industry or
there's going to be some kind of
Armageddon what would you have done the
decision to commit twelve point eight
trillion dollars in guarantees loans to
a financial system dominated by
speculators and remember that in the
17th century speculators were hung has
empowered a criminal class that has not
only trashed the global economy but
robbed small shareholders many of whom
are sitting in this room a month after
month put money aside for retirement and
college and were wiped out and those who
wiped them out figures like Richard Fuld
from Lehman Brothers walked away with
four hundred and eighty five million
dollars in bonuses and compensation Wall
Street is run by a criminal class at
this point and
most of them belong on trial not
subsidized in the most disgusting
example of corporate welfare in human
history
what is so myopic about what's happening
is that corporate is is actually
destroying the socialism that's trying
to save it we a year from now these
corporations are not going to pump this
kind of liquidity into the market and we
are going to be bereft of resources to
respond to the growing desperation that
is sweeping across the country so yeah I
think most of these people belong behind
bars and this is her mr. tenant house
first of all I like to see ya to for you
to defend yourself and secondly I wanted
to ask you a in regard to your book and
if the historian the political historian
Schlesinger jr. said that conservatism
and liberalism came about every 30 years
do you propose that is that part of your
your thinking that's an interesting
question right you talk about the cycles
of history that both Schlesinger first
elder and then younger discussed I draw
on a parallel idea that Schlesinger also
had some interest in that was proposed
by quite brilliant and unsung political
journalists from the 1950s named Sam Lou
Bell's hammer Lubell wrote a really
ingenious book called a future of
American politics and he had what he
called the solar system theory of
democracy in America as far as the two
parties go that what seems to be an
equally balanced two-party system is
actually
actually a history of cycles in which
one party dominates the other that's the
son party he called it in his solar
metaphor and the other party becomes a
minority party the moon party that
orbits around the center so for instance
I'm in 1860 with his in essence the
creation of the modern Republican Party
election of Abraham Lincoln Republicans
really dominated our politics until 1932
there were two Democratic presidents
elected in that period Grover Cleveland
who governed more or less as a Clinton
or Eisenhower did and Woodrow Wilson who
was elected because there was a split
within the Republican Party that opened
the way for him when Theodore Roosevelt
broke away from the Republican Party in
1912 with the election of Franklin
Roosevelt in 32 we saw the rise of the
Democratic son which lasted either till
1968 or 1980 depending on your point of
view that is either with the election of
Nixon or then Reagan in those and we're
not we've now entered a period that one
ended in I think 1992 I think actually
the conservative movement ended with the
election of Bill Clinton we sometimes
forget that out of the last five
presidential elections a plurality of
votes was won by Democrats four times
the only time the Republicans won was in
2004 an election that was misrepresented
as a great sweeping mandate when in fact
it was the closest re-election the
sitting president in modern history who
have the smallest governing majority
than that since McKinley at the end of
the 19th century what happened was in an
analysis not so different I think from
what Chris might say the Republicans had
seized so much control over the
political apparatus and the institutions
in the culture that in 2000 they were
able to put their guy in office and at
that point with September 11th
Republicans have their opportunity
rather the conservatives within the
Republican Party
there were an opportunity to pursue
their agenda any way they liked because
of September 11th with the consequences
we saw
so we have now begun a period I think of
Democratic domination and I would not be
mislead by all the noise and shouting
and fringe insurgencies were seeing on
the right when a party is has no ideas
and no serious governing philosophy
which the Republicans now do not have
that's when the noise gets loudest in
the late 1950s and early 60s another
period when the Republicans were on the
margins with a moon party the loudest
voices came from the John Birch Society
remember their explanation of the
universe is white Eisenhower was a
communist who reported to a superior
communist his brother Milton Eisenhower
and the government was dominated by 70
or 80 percent of Soviet agents who
wanted to poison us to fluoridated water
this was the ideology of the hard right
back then it's not remarkably different
from some of what we hear now the the
birthers for instance a classic kind of
conspiratorial view of government so my
answer to the question is that we have
actually entered a period a dark though
Chris may think it is of democratic
party domination now you know - as far
as Chris's argument about corporatism
versus conservatism that someone wanted
me to address that that may be true I'm
not sure this will appalled many how
terrible that is and how even important
it is because our system is one of
dominated by a sort of a centrist
consensus I think most people don't
stand all that far apart from one
another on a continuum in other words if
in a country of 300 million people a
very large number of them how ever
deluded they may be think that a
capitalist system is the one that's
going to work
and that's the one we're going to have
that I don't think it's imposed by evil
tycoons they may exploit it they may
exploit our fantasies and illusions and
misplaced ambitions but this is still an
aspirational nation most people I think
I may be mistaken look back on our
history and see much to admire and
applaud in it and see great advances
we've made not always directly and not
always as far in the precise direction
we'd all like to go in but essentially
one of improvement and further
democratization and - as long as a
majority of the nation kind of thinks
that way we will get the elected figures
we have I don't think our nation is
really a conspiracy so that's my answer
there George you should say that I want
to just add one thing I think it's true
that the pendulum basically does go back
and forth and clearly last November 4th
it took a decisive turn but each time it
swings it kind of incorporates what just
came before it it doesn't negate it it
incorporates it and what's just come
before Obama's presidency is the most
far-reaching radical in Sam's words and
I think effective assault on the idea
that government has a central role in
the well-being of American citizens in
our history I mean we've always been an
anti-government country with the
Revolution was an anti-government
revolution and that idea has been
powerful but it's always been tempered
because there were elements of both
parties that saw something important in
government during the Civil War Lincoln
represented the idea of strong
government Teddy Roosevelt did for the
Republican Party against the trus
Woodrow Wilson brought it to the
Democratic Party with a different idea
about what what Chris calls corporatism
Roosevelt sort of was the the apogee of
the idea of government centrality in our
lives but it has been so undermined by
both a sustained political and
propaganda assault I mean the media
plays a big role in this and also by the
failure of 30 years of government to
reverse the decline in living standards
of millions and millions of Americans so
that now and this is something I found
while reporting last year in Ohio during
the campaign people who stand to benefit
enormous Lee from health care reform are
deeply suspicious of health care reform
now why is that I have they been deluded
by Fox News I try to stay away from the
conspiratorial explanation because I
think it takes away the agency and the
ability of individuals to kind of come
to their own conclusions this is why I
focus on individuals in my reporting
what do they think about their own lives
that's what ultimately matters and in
Ohio what they thought was one Obama is
two-thirds Arab is one woman told me but
two I asked where'd you hear that on the
internet but two that the government
isn't going to do it whatever they do
they're going to either screw it up or
it's going to benefit either rich people
or the shiftless idle poor who are on
welfare it's not going to benefit me
that's what I was hearing from third
generation coal mining families in the
Appalachian part of Ohio who were the
backbone of the pro-government
Democratic Party during the period of
Roosevelt and Truman and I think Obama
understood that and he had a hard time
with those voters he eat out just enough
votes in those areas to win Ohio and to
win Indiana but if he is going to be a
successful president he has to convince
those people and millions of others that
government can be a force for good in
their lives because they're not looking
for government to do something they are
skeptical bitter angry and that's why
they're always a very easy target for
for the right-wing and when Obama made
that slip about you know bitter voters
clinging to their guns
it was a very unfortunate thing to say
because it was I thought condescending
but he was hitting at exactly what I'm
saying and I think he was right that
these voters have been seeing their
lives getting harder and harder for so
long that they no longer trust the
Democratic Party or the government to do
anything about it and right now I'd say
Obama is running some risk especially in
his economic policies of a backlash next
year even if we're at the beginning of
an age of Democratic dominance I think
there could be a real backlash because
some of these policies don't seem to be
benefiting anyone but an elite health
care reform well you know I'm sure Obama
himself is an advocate of single-payer
in his heart but he's not going to get
it because the Sam says we're not a
nation of single-payer supporters so
he's getting he and Congress are in that
in the unbelievably disappointing and an
and slow and sort of repellent process
that is legislative democracy are trying
to reform the health care system I think
that will be the key to whether he he
and the Democrats do well by the voters
next year if they cannot control both
the legislative and executive and yet
health care reform the voters will
punish them badly a year from now let me
just quickly add something to that
having spent two years writing a book on
the Christian Right I spent a lot of
time in these former manufacturing
centers like Youngstown and and George
is right this bitterness and much of my
own family comes from former mill towns
in Maine utterly destroyed by NAFTA
NAFTA 1994 passed by Democratic
administration thrust about a knife into
the back of the American working class
it was a tremendous betrayal and when
you talk about blue-collar workers being
angry at liberals and voting against
their own interests I think that's
incorrect
liberals betrayed the working class in
this country and the working class
understood the vast hypocrisy on the
part of a bankrupt liberal elite that
continued to talk in the language
of democracy and workers rights and year
after year supported a democratic party
that betrayed those rights whether it
was so-called welfare reform or the
destruction of glass-steagall and what
we have done by allowing corporations to
literally dismantle our manufacturing
base is not only create a frightening
kind of alienation and engender deep
personal and economic
among the working class but permanently
disenfranchised the working class these
jobs at least the kinds of jobs that you
had in mills and steel mills is not
they're not coming back
it's why you have people you know
struggling 2 3 4 jobs taking jobs in
Walmart where they're below the poverty
line and that disempowerment of the
citizenry that Vollmer ization of the
american working class is creating an
oligarchic system and you cannot sustain
a functioning or a healthy democracy in
an oligarchy and that's something that
even the ancient Greek writers on
democracy like Plutarch and Thucydides
understood so I think that we are not
seeing traditional conservatism we are
seeing something far more radical in the
form of American corporatism well it is
no loyalty to America in terms of
globalization and corporatism which is
literally hollowing out our country from
the inside and the rise of the corporate
state has grave political consequences
as we saw in Italy and Germany in the
early part of the 20th century and I
just add you have
yeah oh yeah go ahead much of what the
three of you have said I feel is
attributable to a phenomenon that had
goes by the name of the Overton Window
which describes shifting what is
currently acceptable to a more radical
position so that we accept things like
Fox News which is really Fox propaganda
we accept things that the corporate is
has enjoys personhood which is the
position of the Supreme Court after the
last few decades and other examples many
of which I think that you guys have
detailed what I want to ask you is the
Republicans it slash conservatives have
been very successful at moving the
Overton Window and the liberal slash
Democrats have been notably unsuccessful
Oh can you give us your ideas as to why
that is so
can I offer one quick explanation that's
mentioned in my book in a very brilliant
political analyst who once actually
worked in both the Kennedy and Johnson
administration's said when it he said
conservatives have a genius for the
semantics of political debate he said
for instance national health insurance
is recast as socialized medicine and the
opposition to a minimum wage is called
the right to work the Southern Strategy
is in the well for racial bigotry
Richard Goodwin wrote that in 1967 and
the actual terms are still in use today
and what the right was able to do at
that point was to create a rhetoric that
was more effective in reaching the pot
Sam why why don't
Chris's terms buy more ization neo
feudalism corporatism
push aside socialized medicine and
the rest of the rights were slogan well
one answer to that would be that here's
an interesting contradiction we have
that now those are the terms you use
George I don't know if Chris embraces
them but Chris you do yeah okay just
embrace them buddy use them well here's
part of it here's part of the problem it
was something I wanted to mention before
everything Chris said about the working
class and and the blue-collar worker is
true and he said that the jobs in the
manufacturing jobs are not coming back
what happened to John McCain in the 2008
primary when he went to Michigan and
said exactly that
he would he lost badly that's where my
book is called empire of illusion well
the problem is if if so much if the very
voters that are affected by these
drastic down shifts in their economic
status won't accept the argument when
it's presented to them then you have a
kind of cognitive dissonance which is
part of the problem let me just a second
thing that the terms that that Chris
used and that you mentioned here George
I fear I may be wrong but they don't
resonate those are terms that even if
they are advanced in the interests of
the working class sound like the
language of the Harvard seminar room
whereas the what the the addendum that
Goodwin had was the reason Republicans
are so good at this or we really said
conservatives because in those days
there were liberal Republicans and
moderate Republicans there aren't
anymore there were back then is because
yet to write is because they always seem
to make the issue national security or
the national in basically Sam the
Republicans from McCarthy to Reagan and
Gingrich seized the populist language
and took it from the left and moved it
to the right and populism has this very
old history in our country it goes back
to Jefferson and Jackson in the 1890s
farmers and workers joined together to
create the People's Party which was a
populist party in the 30s there was a
challenge to Roosevelt from the left
coming from Huey Long in other words
that was populist in the 60s there was
populism
in the language of the protesters but it
moved to the right Kris is essentially
in the tradition of left-wing populism
I mean what kris has said today is in
different terms and maybe it's the
language of the Harvard seminar room
maybe it's not is very much the same
point of view that the pot that the
farmers of the 1890s had that the
bankers and the railroads and the robber
barons as they call them then maybe it
was a better language maybe it was more
colorful um robber barons has stuck with
us because it's such a good term maybe
the right wing had that genius for
finding those terms that stick and
that's half the battle in politics it is
a an undercurrent in American politics
that has been with us from the beginning
and Kris is a very articulate spokesman
for my feeling is it doesn't win it
doesn't win elections but it what it
does do is push the Democratic Party to
the left we are a reformist nation we
are not a radical nation I think Sam's
right about that and I think Chris's
language and point of view will not
become majoritarian and will not win
national elections but it could force
the Democrats who do in elections to be
more radical in their reform let me let
me just quickly first of all you know
most of my relatives at best finished
high school they can certainly
understand this language however in fact
that I have been by Harvard
second of all we forgot Karl poppers
great dictum that the question is not
how to get good people to rule the
question because most people attracted
to power are mediocre at best and often
venal the the question is how do we stop
the powerful from doing as much damage
as they can to us and that becomes by
building movements that frighten those
in power you talk about Sam talks about
Nixon being the last liberal president
and he's right but Richard Nixon at his
heart was not a liberal he was just
frightened of movements of the labor
movement of the civil rights movement
and of the anti-war movement and all of
the correctives in American democracy
have not come from the top including the
New Deal they came from movements the
suffragettes the Liberty party that
fought slavery and the bankruptcy of
American liberalism is that it became
entranced by power our job if you care
about the working class in this country
is to build movements movements as I
used to live in France and saw that
frightened people in power people like
Richard Nixon who did not have a moral
bone in his body
to pass the Clean Water Act and supports
civil rights legislation and that's been
our failure
we have been seduced by a corporatized
Democratic Party and and that has had
terrifying consequences for our
democracy actually the reason Nixon
passed civil rights legislation and
advocated affirmative action was because
he knew it was going to break up the
Democratic Party and that's exactly what
happened that's how Machiavellian
richard nixon was which by the way
is not necessarily the worst way for a
politician to operate so what's our
thank you
oh yeah one more question I would throw
in Bismarck Ian might be the best
description as generalist this is a
question for each of you
24 hour news has increased this bit of
speech speed of news
so implement the news is getting dumber
secondly uh I'm sorry to tell the news
is getting is get dumber yeah
it's dumb down blogs allow everybody to
retreat into their own groups and not
have any proof of anything and we have
hallucinations of death panels and 9/11
conspiracies and thirdly um mainstream
media hosts seem seduced very often by
the illusions and myths of the power
elite if you want to call them that and
like they won't quite like the wholly up
to the Iraq war there was no evidence
for the weapons mass destruction but
they all believed it so what can Jen
let's do to bring more reality into the
debate and more proof in higher
standards so that we have real
information to reach real solutions with
I think the first thing they can do is
survive I mean you've that's a brilliant
distillation of what is wrong with our
media the thing you said about people
moving into their ideological corners as
more web sites proliferate and Cass
Sunstein who now works for the Obama
administration called that niche
extremism in other words the more sites
there are the more segregated we are
ideologically and the more extreme we
become because the web is not a source
of news it's a source of opinion and it
preys upon and is parasitic upon news
which comes from other sources like the
New York Times for example well right
now the New York Times is trying to fire
a hundred people
well we're offering them by
now I don't know what the person thinks
about that so maybe I shouldn't you know
the Washington Post is becoming a shell
of itself the Los Angeles Times long ago
stopped being itself the Chicago Tribune
I'm sure you've got your Florida
counterparts um I how's the Herald doing
is the very tough be I mean the fact
that the st. Petersburg Times is still
alive is due to the fact that it's
supported by a nonprofit Institute the
Pointer so we are the greatest threat
right now to maybe to our democracy is
the fact that they're the economic model
that supported serious news gathering
and in my case serious narrative
journalism in a long form it has
collapsed and no one has figured out how
to replicate it on the web so the first
question is not you know what can
journalists do to improve its what can
journalists do to stay in their jobs
it's a cultural problem we are shifting
from a print-based society to an image
based society something writers like
Neil postman wrote eloquently about and
that has terrifying consequences we are
a society utterly awash in lies
skillfully manipulated images that make
us confuse how we are made to feel with
knowledge you talk about health care why
do we fear universal health care or what
are some elements of the society fear it
well because we speak talk and think in
the idiom of popular culture which is
about linguistically at about a sixth
grade level and the refusal to to
disconnect from these images and end and
and study issues outside of the jargon
and cliches that are handed to us by one
side or another has rendered us impotent
this is not a new phenomenon throughout
history Cicero wrote about it when he
decried the spectacle of the Roman arena
and we are
moving away from nuanced thought from
the struggle with ambiguity for this
kind of childish can that if someone
mentioned FoxNews that dominates most of
the cable news networks and so when we
watch the death of newspapers of you
know of Philadelphia Inquirer San
Francisco Chronicle all in bankruptcy
proceedings
the New York Times struggling we are
seeing the dying gasps of a culture that
is severing itself from print and
entering an age of terrifying illiteracy
there have been other periods in human
history when populations have been
illiterate but no society has been able
to replicate reality to such an extent
that we confuse pseudo events and images
for reality itself a third of the
country is illiterate forty-two million
Americans cannot read and about 50
million Americans read at a fourth or
fifth grade level and then there are
people who are functionally literate but
who don't read anymore and that has
political and social consequences that I
think we are watching in as we see the
death of print and we and I think George
is right a democracy that severs itself
from the print based world and from
newspapers which for all of their flaws
and and they have many and there are
subservience to advertisers and
commercialism nevertheless
hold entire cities community means that
huge sections of America will in essence
go dark nobody will be at City Hall
nobody will be covering the police and
the ability for corruption and the abuse
of power by our power elite will grow
exponentially
thank you thank you all very much that
wraps it up I hope you've enjoyed this
book this ayah
Oh
ladies and gentlemen mr. Tannen house
has one last comment please supreme
court was all I was going to say is I'm
afraid both my colleagues are absolutely
right I wanted to add one more thing
however and because it was much talk
about newspapers I think what were most
in danger of losing I think there is a
fair amount of reading in some ways all
too much reading that goes on in front
of computers and online and people are
assimilating little bits of information
as both my co-panelists have described
what I worry about most is what kind of
writing we're going to get from the
internet not just what people read but
how do you take essays like George's a
very brilliantly reported stories from
Iraq six and eight and ten thousand
words I don't see how they're going to
be read in any form but a kind of
concrete holdable print form and that
may actually change the way prose is
written in this country are you offering
me a buyout so I really you know the guy
who edits a book review I'm really
worried about that too so thank you all
thank you